[Musik]
bis bald gast ist breit die blm unic
vielen dank für die freundliche
vorstellung und für die einladung zu
dieser sehr interessanten
vorlesungsreihe hin hier in münchen
personen leben nicht nur in der zeit
sondern sie wissen auch von ihrer
zeitlichen existenz sie haben ein
bewusstsein dass sie verschiedene
lebensphasen durchlaufen sich in
vielfacher hinsicht verändern aber
dennoch dieselben erfahrungs objekte
bleiben
dieses bewusstsein spielt für das
moralische und rechtliche verhalten von
personen eine wichtige rolle
wussten wir nicht dass wir als dieselben
erfahrung subjekte über die zeit hinweg
existierten würden wir uns für unsere
früheren taten nicht verantwortlich
fühlen was wir zu einem früheren
zeitpunkt getan hätten würde uns heute
vermutlich nichts angehen
denn uns würde dass der bewusste bezug
zu unserer früheren existenz fehlen und
wenn andere uns zur verantwortung
gezogen würden wir uns nicht persönlich
für unsere handlungen verantwortlich
fühlen
das bewusstsein über die zeit hinweg zu
existieren ist also eine voraussetzung
für die einsicht in das eigene frühere
verhalten
mein vortrag wird sich mit einer
grundlegenden bedingungen für diese
moralisch relevante zurechenbarkeit
befassen
im zentrum wird die frage stehen was es
heißt dass personen sich als dieselben
identischen erfahrungs subjekte
verstehen obwohl sie sich im laufe der
zeit verändern um sich dessen bewusst zu
sein
es ist nicht notwendig komplizierte
reflexionen oder logische operationen
durchzuführen
unser gegenwarts bewusstsein basiert
unter anderem auf dem impliziten
bewusstsein zu einem früheren zeitpunkt
bereits existiert zu hören
diese beschreibung deutet darauf hin
dass das bewusstsein der eigenen ford
dauer also der numerischen identität
über die zeit hinweg vor allem durch
erlebnisse
nicht proposition aale eigenschaften
gekennzeichnet ist
dies legt die frage nahe ob diese
erlebnis haften eigenschaften nicht nur
eine bedeutung für das erlebende subjekt
haben sondern eventuell auch eine
theoretische funktion in bezug auf das
philosophische problem der personale
identität über über die zeit hinweg
könnten erlebnis hafte eigenschaften als
kriterium für personale identität über
die zeit hinweg fungieren
ich werde in meinem vortrag ein
entsprechendes argument von barry denton
diskutieren denken behauptet dass die
kontinuität des erlebens der sogenannte
erlebnis strom für das fortbestehen von
personen eine entscheidende rolle spielt
obwohl es aus meiner sicht grundsätzlich
richtig ist qualitative eigenschaften
mentale zustände bei der analyse von
personaler identität zu berücksichtigen
werde ich zeigen dass denkens vorschlag
mit unüberwindlichen problemen behaftet
ist
daher werde ich anschließend einen ganz
anderen problem einsatz vorschlagen die
relevanz von qualitativen oder erlebnis
haften eigenschaften wird erkennbar wenn
man abdrückt von der suche nach
kriterien für die zeit übergreifende
identität und stattdessen die struktur
und den gehalt des bewusstseins der
eigenen zeit übergreifenden identität in
den blick nimmt und analysiert mein
vortrag hat folgenden aufbau im ersten
teil werde ich erstmal denkens argument
näher erläutern
dann im zweiten abschnitt werde ich zwei
einwände gegen die zentralen prämissen
des arguments vorstellen
woraus aus meiner sicht eben folgt dass
das argument scheitert im letzten teil
und dritten teil werde ich einen eigenen
vorschlag für eine strukturelle analyse
des identitäts bewusstseins von personen
machen und die rolle von erlebnis haften
aspekten bestimmter mentale zustände
charakterisieren
bevor ich mit dem eigentlichen thema
beginnen möchte ich einige begriffliche
und wichtige unterscheidung voranstellen
diese unterscheidung betrifft den
begriff der identität der mehrdeutig und
missverständlich ist es gibt zwei
bedeutungen die in philosophischen
debatten oftmals verwechselt werden
die erste bedeutung um die es in meinem
vortrag nicht geht ist die eher alltag
sprachliche bedeutung von identität ja
also hier im alltag sprachlichen
bedeutung wird der ausdruck
typischerweise gebraucht um auf die
persönlichkeit oder auch den
persönlichkeits kern einer person zu
verweisen
was eine person ausmacht sie auch von
anderen unterscheidet ist ihre identität
zu drücken wir uns im alltag manchmal
aus diese identität kann gefährdet sein
man kann in eine identitätskrise geraten
man kann seine identität verlieren oder
auch wiederfinden
diese bedeutung von identität gehört der
semantik von persönlichkeit an
allerdings wird die seit wortsinn oft
vermengt mit einer gänzlich anderen
bedeutung von identität denn der
ausdruck identität verweist in
bestimmten philosophischen debatten auf
einer logische relation zwischen
entitäten die zu unterschiedlichen
zeitpunkten existieren ja die relevante
frage lautet hier handelt es sich bei
den identitäten zu verschiedenen
zeitpunkten um ein und dieselbe entität
also numerisch eine oder um zwei
verschiedene also angenommen ich treffe
auf der straße auf eine person die mich
an jemanden erinnert mit dem ich zur
grundschule gegangen bin ja das ist
schon sehr lange her aber diese person
erinnert mich an diesen menschen nun
kann ich mich fragen handelt es sich bei
der person tatsächlich um meinen
ehemaligen schulkameradin oder ist es
vielleicht eine andere person
ja also kann es sein dass die person
meiner meine schulkameraden einfach nur
ähnlich sieht aber es ist gar nicht
peter sondern es ist vielleicht klaus ja
und hier frage ich eben hier stelle ich
die frage nach der numerischen identität
zwischen meinem alten schulkameraden
peter und der person die ich da auf der
straße treffe ist ein und dieselbe
person oder nicht doch eine andere
identität wird in diesem kontext also
verstanden als numerische identität über
die zeit hinweg was in den
englischsprachigen debatten auch häufig
als selbe ich kai chemnitz bezeichnet
wird wenn ich im folgenden von identität
sprecher dann verwende ich den ausdruck
in der bedeutung von numerischer
identität also in dieser zweiten
bedeutung und auch brauche ich manchmal
den etwas sperrigen ausdruck zeit
übergreifende oder auch trans temporale
identität philosophische theorien die
sich mit diesem begriff der identität
befassen fragen typischerweise nach
bedingungen die erfüllt sein müssen
damit man korrekter weise sagen kann
dass eine person als numerisch
identisches einzel ding ford existiert
welche annahmen machen wir wenn wir
behaupten dass ein kind im jahr 1980 und
eine erwachsene person im jahr 2014
numerisch identisch sind
die mehrzahl der heute gängigen ansätze
definieren personale identität über die
zeit hinweg im rückgriff auf körperliche
oder psychische kontinuität
also wenn ein bestimmtes individuum zu
t1 also zu einem bestimmten zeitpunkt
und ein bestimmtes individuum zu einem
anderen zeitpunkt t2 in körperlicher
oder psychischer kontinuität zueinander
stehen dann handelt es sich um ein und
dasselbe identische individuum ja so die
gängigen ansätze heutzutage die
wenigsten ansätze stellen aber explizit
die perspektive der ersten person und
erlebnis hafteigenschaften mentaler
zuständen
aus meiner sicht ist das problematisch
weil man so einen zentralen aspekt des
selbstverständnisses von personen von
vornherein ausschließt personen haben
normalerweise ein bewusstsein davon dass
sie als erfahrungs objekte in der zeit
existieren
selbst in abwesenheit konkrete
erinnerungen wissen personen zumindest
implizit dass sie auch bereits in der
vergangenheit als erfahrungs objekte
existiert haben diese information wird
typischerweise nicht logisch erschlossen
sie ist auch nicht das ergebnis einer
komplexen überlegung also scheint es
sich darum also um ein bewusstseins
inhalt zu handeln der vor allem durch
erlebnis hafte oder phänomenale
eigenschaften gekennzeichnet ist lässt
sich aber behaupten dass subjektives
erleben für personale identität über die
zeit hinweg konstitutiv ist dies
behauptet barry dienten
er argumentiert dass all unsere mentale
zustände teil eines kontinuierlichen
erlebnis stroms sind und dieser erlebnis
strom ist dem argument zufolge für die
numerische identität von personen sowohl
notwendig als auch hinreichend um die
grundidee des ansatzes besser
verständlich zu machen müssen zunächst
einige begriffe und annahmen erläutert
werden
was genau sind eigentlich erlebnis hafte
oder auch qualitative eigenschaften der
ausdruck verweist der debatten
typischerweise auf den phänomenalen
charakter mentale zustände also darauf
wie es sich anfühlt in einem bestimmten
mentalen zustand zu sein
im unterschied zu einem anderen mentalen
zustand wenn ich zum beispiel eine grell
grüne wiese sehe dann fühlt sich diese
farbwahrnehmung auf eine ganz bestimmte
art und weise an
sie hat einen charakteristischen
erlebnis aspekt und wenn ich meinen
blick dann auf einen dunklen see richte
dann fühlt sich dies auf eine andere
weise
während standard auffassungen solche
qualitativen erlebnis haften
eigenstetter eigenschaften zumeist auf
sensorische zustände wie also der
farbwahrnehmung und schmerzzustände
beschränken vertritt denken auf dessen
argumente ich mich gleich bezieher
demgegenüber die these dass solche
eigenschaften sämtliche typen mentale
zustände charakter charakterisieren also
nicht nur empfindungen wahrnehmung und
gefühle schmerzzustände sondern auch
gedanken und überlegungen auch der
hintergrund von inhaltlich konkreten
erfahrungen ist qualitativ eingefärbt
zum beispiel eine stimmung oder eine
erlebte atmosphäre entscheidend für das
argument von denton ist jedoch die art
wie mehrere erlebnis zustände
miteinander verbunden sind verschiedene
erlebnis zustände treten im normalfall
nicht isoliert voneinander auf sondern
zusammen oder auch genauer sie treten
als eine einheit auf sie können zwar im
hinblick auf ihren gehalt und modus
voneinander unterschieden werden
dennoch sind sie aber bewusst wie denken
sich ausdrückt insofern sie einem
einzelnen übergreifenden gesamtzustand
angehören also beispielsweise ich stehe
jetzt hier am pult und ich habe auch
unterschiedliche erlebnisse und
empfindungen zustände
ich habe taktile empfindungen ja also
meine hand berührt dieses pult ich habe
olfaktorischen empfindungen ja dieser
ich habe natürlich auch eine bestimmte
berufe empfindung
ich habe visuelle empfindungen ich sehe
verschiedene farben farben und aber auch
form ja das passiert eben alles
gleichzeitig wichtig im vorliegenden
kontext ist allerdings dass auch solche
erlebnisse die nicht simultan auftreten
also nicht gleichzeitig auftreten durch
phänomenale einheit gekennzeichnet
anknüpfungspunkt dieser analyse ist
zunächst mal die beobachtung die auch
ursprünglich auf usa zurückgeht dass
verschiedene bewusste mentale zustände
nicht plötzlich auftauchen und
anschließend ebenso abrupt wieder
verschwinden sondern sie gehen
unmittelbar ineinander über
dies wird deutlich wenn man sich
beispielsweise das geräusch eines autos
das vor dem fenster vorbei fährt
vorstellt jede phase dieser auditiven
wahrnehmung fließt nahtlos in die
nächste über und ohne unterbrechung
zeitversetzt auftretende bewusste
mentale zustände sind nicht nur direkt
miteinander verbunden sondern sie werden
als verbunden erlebt das beispiel macht
deutlich dass es in der kontinuität von
erfahrungen momente gibt in denen man
die veränderungen mentaler gehalte und
deren zeitliche streckung direkt bemerkt
ein solcher moment ist jedoch von
vergleichsweise kurzer dauer
dies wird in theorien des zeit
bewusstseins oftmals als flüchtiger
gegenwarts moment bezeichnet species
präsent jetzt auch ein terminus der viel
von william james eingesetzt wurde und
ihn eigentlich auch durch james berühmt
gemacht hat weil es einen gegenwärtig
gegenwärtig bewusst ist dauert weniger
als eine sekunde an der aktuell erlebt
im moment ist so insofern kein
ausgedehnter punkt den man zwischen der
unmittelbaren vergangenheit und der noch
nicht eingetreten in zukunft verordnen
muss und der als solcher verschwindet
vielmehr hat er eine zeitliche streckung
es gibt frühere und spätere abschnitte
dieses erlebten gegenwarts moment wie
das beispiel des allmählichen verklingen
des motorengeräusche zeigt die übergänge
zwischen den zeitlichen abschnitten also
den früheren und späteren werden direkt
wahrgenommen nachdenken sind diese
zeitlichen abschnitt abschnitte
qualitativ miteinander verbunden dass
sie sind also ebenfalls co bewusst in
den denkens terminologie
diese beschreibung bezieht sich jedoch
zunächst nur auf das erleben des
einzelnen zeitlichen zeitlich
ausgedehnten gegenwarts moment die these
von denton lautet aber weiter dass
zwischen den gegenwärtig erlebt momenten
ebenfalls eine vollständige phänomenale
verbindung besteht
verbindungen die als solche eben erlebt
werden
die gegenwärtig lebten momente fließen
ganz und gar lückenlos ineinander
daraus ergibt sich folgendes bild
einzelne erfahrungen die nicht
gleichzeitig auftreten gehören demselben
bewusstseinsstrom an wenn sie über die
zeit hinweg qualitativ miteinander
verbunden also bewusst sind diese
verbindungen bestehen entweder direkt
das heißt sie treten in demselben
erlebten gegenwarts abschnitt als [ __ ]
is present ab auf oder indirekt dann
gehören sie einer kette von sich
überlappenden gegenwarts momenten an ein
bewusstseinsstrom ist also keine bloße
aufeinanderfolge oder aneinanderreihung
von einzelnen mentalen zuständen sondern
eine art fließende sequenz die andauert
obwohl man kaum jemals bewusst notiz von
ihr nimmt es handelt sich hierbei um
einen fall phänomenaler kontinuität die
denkens argument zur folge sofern sie
gegeben ist die zeit übergreifende
identität von personen garantiert ja
also eine person zum zeitpunkt t1 und
eine person zum zeitpunkt der 2 sind
diesem argument zufolge genau dann ein
und dieselbe person wenn zwischen ihnen
eine erlebnis hafte verbindung vorliegt
wenn sie also aufgrund eines
einheitlichen bewusstseins stroms
miteinander verbunden sind
ja das argument wirkt auf den ersten
blick gar nicht so unklar dass die
fortdauer von personen durch kontinuität
des erlebens bedingt ist scheint auch
unseren alltags intuitionen zu
entsprechen
zum einen besteht diese kontinuität auch
dann wenn erfahrung subjekte sie nicht
bewusst
explizit wahrnehmen ja die existenz des
erlebnis stroms ist eben an keine
kognitive leistung höherer ordnung
gebunden zum anderen sichert die
kontinuität des erlebens erlebnis stroms
auch dann die fortdauer der person wenn
der fall einer diskontinuität bestimmter
psychischer zustände und fähigkeiten
eintreten würde zum beispiel durch den
verlust von konkreten erinnerungen
irgendwelchen vorlieben vielleicht auch
längerfristige überzeugungen wenn
beispielsweise jemand in folge eines
hirnschlags eine vielzahl seiner
persönlichen erinnerungen eingebüßt
hätte würde man nicht denn aussagen dass
sie personen vor und nach diesem
ereignis numerisch dieselbe ist und eben
nicht zwei verschiedene dass wir geneigt
sind die frage mit ja zu beantworten
hängt auch damit zusammen dass die
subjektive erfahrungs perspektive den
faktischen verlust von konkreten
inhalten also erinnerungen
längerfristigen absichten und vorlieben
überdauert auch wenn bestimmte eng
codierte mentale inhalte aufhörte zu
existieren würde die erfahrung subjekt
perspektive fortbestehen und das deutet
darauf hin dass kontinuierliche
qualitative eigenschaften in der tat für
trans temporale personenidentität
relevant sind
dennoch muss sich die theorie einem ganz
entscheidenden problem stellen
dies wird deutlich wenn man längere
zeitabschnitte in betracht zieht denn
was geschieht eigentlich wenn die zeit
punkte sammeln matti 1 und t5 zu dir zu
den personen existieren länger zum
beispiel einige tage auseinander liegen
es ist tatsächlich vorstellbar dass die
personen phänomenal durch einen
lückenlosen erlebnis strom miteinander
verbunden sind
dass dies unwahrscheinlich ist hängt
damit zusammen dass ein erlebnis strom
normalerweise nicht besonders lang
andauern
ja phänomenale kontinuität wird
üblicherweise immer wieder unterbrochen
was wäre so eine typische länge eines
erlebnis stroms es ist davon auszugehen
dass dieser zumindest für die dauer des
wach zustands andauert im wachzustand
erlebt ein empfindungsfähigkeit stets
etwas ja in unterschiedlichen und auch
wechselnden geraden der ihnen in
intensität
man könnte vielleicht ebenso behaupten
wie denken ist auch tut das niedrig
stufe also niedrig stufige also nur so
unterschwellig bewusste erfahrungen
sogar in phasen des leichten
oberflächlichen schlafs und träumens
andauern
allerdings wird spätestens im zustand
des traum losen schlafes oder auch unter
vollnarkose der bewusstseins fluss
unzweifelhaft unterbrochen
dieses problem was denken auch sieht
wird als brücken problem bezeichnet zu
beachten ist dass es dabei keineswegs um
eine bloße einschränkung der aussage des
arguments geht vielmehr hängt das
gesamte argument überzeit übergreifende
personenidentität entscheidend von einer
akzeptablen lösung des brücken problems
ab um die gültigkeit des arguments zu
erhalten also nochmal personale
identität über die zeit hinweg ist
nichts anderes als phänomenal
kontinuität bedarf es zusätzlicher
prämissen in erster linie muss gezeigt
werden welche art von verbindungen
zwischen phasen tatsächlich
kontinuierlichen erlebens und gänzlich
bewusstlosen phasen besteht diese
verbindung also die überbrückung kommt
eine zentrale funktion innerhalb des
arguments zu denn sie also diese
überbrückung muss für phänomenale
kontinuität und damit für identität
notwendig und hinreichend sein
es muss sich um eine verbindung handeln
die sich auf alle denkbaren fälle
phänomenaler diskontinuität
erstreckt der grund grundsätzlich gibt
es zwei offenkundige möglichkeiten das
brücken problem anzugehen
zum einen könnte man behaupten dass
bewusstseins ströme schlicht und
ergreifend irgendwann enden und ebenso
die existenz von personen
diese radikale lösung favorisiert zum
beispiel gelten sprossen
sie ist allerdings mit dem problem
behaftet dass sie unserem alltags
verständnis stark zuwiderläuft
ja also niemand würde behaupten nur weil
wir in der vergangenen nacht in
tiefschlaf gefallen sind dass wir heute
also dass wir heute als neue personen
anfangen zu existieren man könnte auch
gar keine sinnvollen aussagen über etwas
tätigen was einem gestern widerfahren
ist weil das einfach gar keine sinnvolle
aussage mehr wäre denn man müsste ja
dieser ansicht zufolge behaupten dass
man gestern eine andere person war die
dann eben zum zeit des tiefschlafs
aufgehört hat zu existieren
und dann hat eine neue person angefangen
zu existieren mit dem aufwachen
es ist er nicht nicht wahnsinnig
plausibel
zum anderen könnte man aber im gegenteil
behaupten dass der bewusstseinsstrom
selbst in phasen des traum losen
tiefschlafs andauert auch wenn das
erfahrung subjekt davon überhaupt keine
notiz nimmt
diese sichtweise vertritt wiederum
johann gustafsson
damit würde man behaupten dass es ein
brücken problem letztlich gar nicht gibt
diese variante ist allerdings in
begrifflicher oder auch sachlicher
hinsicht problematisch da der begriff
des erlebnis stroms auf unbewusste
zustände und so personalprozesse
ausgeweitet würde für keine dieser
strategien entscheidet sich denken als
tatsache wird zwar akzeptiert das
bewusstsein ströme nicht ewig andauern
sondern bisweilen langsam verklingen
oder enden und neue zu einem späteren
zeitpunkt beginnen
aber genau dies
zeigt dass der bewusstseinsstrom als
solcher also für sich genommen in keiner
interessanten weise etwas zur frage der
zeit übergreifenden personenidentität
beisteuern können um allerdings an der
grundlegenden idee festzuhalten bedarf
es einer modifikation der übergreifenden
these oder wie denken es ausdrückt einer
perspektivischen verschiebung nicht die
aktuelle tatsächlich gegebene
kontinuierliche erfahrung wird als
hinreichend für die fortexistenz einer
numerisch identischen wert person
betrachtet sondern die fähigkeit zu
einer einheitlichen kontinuierlichen
erfahrung erfahrungs objekte produzieren
zwar nicht immer bewusster erfahrung die
definitorischen mit anderen erfahrungen
qualitativ verknüpft sind erfahrung
sagte besitzen jedoch die fähigkeit
zugangs und gar lückenlosen bewusstsein
in phasen der abwesenheit des erlebnis
stroms hört eine person demnach nicht
einfach auf zu existieren
denn sie besitzt ja die fähigkeit
fähigkeit zu kontinuierlichen
bewusstsein denken zufolge existiert
also eine person als numerisch eine
person
solange die bloße fähigkeit gegeben ist
unabhängig davon ob die fähigkeit
ausgeübt wird oder nicht
mein erster einwand bezieht sich vor
allem auf die funktionen welche die
fähigkeit innerhalb des arguments der
trans temporalen identität übernehmen
soll
obwohl denken zu recht eine präzisierung
dessen anstrebt was es heißt diese
bestimmte fähigkeit zu haben bin ich der
auffassung dass das übergreifende
problem auf diese weise nicht gelöst
werden kann
dabei ist vor allem zu beachten dass der
fokus des arguments aufgrund des brücken
problems verschoben wird ja von
aktueller phänomenaler kontinuität hin
zur entsprechenden fähigkeit von der
behauptet wird dass sie sowohl notwendig
als auch hinreichend für trans temporale
identität sei bevor dieser
perspektivwechsel verschoben wurde
schien für die begründung in
begrifflicher hinsicht einiges zu
sprechen angesichts der tatsache dass
personen genuin empfindung
beziehungsweise erlebniswege wesen sind
wird man ja kaum leugnen können dass
eine person weiterhin existiert so lange
sie tatsächlich kontinuierlich bei
bewusstsein ist also etwas erlebt dies
zeigt dass der gedanke der phänomenalen
kontinuität mit der fortdauer einer
person begrifflich direkt verbunden ist
phänomenale kontinuität ist nichts
anderes als eine lückenlose kette trans
temporär mentale ereignisse die einem
subjekt angehören
diese begriffliche verbindung ist im
falle der bloßen fähigkeit zu
phänomenaler kontinuität jedoch nicht
gegeben
der grund hierfür ist dass personen
normalerweise über eine erhebliche
anzahl an fähigkeiten verfügen warum
sollte von all diesen ausgerechnet die
fähigkeit zu phänomenaler kontinuität
konstitutiv für trans temporale
personenidentität seien in theoretischer
hinsicht erscheint es willkürlich welche
fähigkeit man als prämisse in das
argument einbaut
wir werden nachdenken die existenz einer
fähigkeit notwendig und hinreichend für
trans zentrale personenidentität ist
dann sehe ich nicht warum eine
spezifische fähigkeit theoretisch
privilegierter sein soll als eine andere
etwa die erinnerungsfähigkeit oder die
fähigkeit zu denken oder zu entscheiden
doch nehmen wir dem argument zu lieber
einmal an die fähigkeit zu einem
kontinuierlichen bewusstsein strom kann
als theoretisch privilegiert ausgewiesen
werden
dann stellt sich dennoch die frage ob
der ansatz dass einlöst wasser
verspricht nämlich personale identität
durch erlebnis hafte eigenschaften zu
begründen unklar ist wie die existenz
einer bloßen fähigkeit eine erlebnis
hafte verbindung zwischen zwei
tatsächlich erlebnis haften zuständen
oder auch erlebnis strömen bereitstellen
soll
dabei ist zu beachten dass die
einführung des begriffs der fähigkeit ja
auch zum ziel hatte
das problem der unterbrechung des
erlebnis stroms zu lösen dass das heißt
die abwesenheit ja eigentlich von
erlebnissen zu überbrücken
dasjenige was diese funktion übernehmen
soll kann definitionsgemäß nicht selbst
erlebnis haft seien
wäre es tatsächlich der fall dass die
zeit über greifen die identität der
person im rückgriff auf erlebnis
hafteigenschaften analysiert würde
was denken mit seinem ansatz ja
behauptet dann würde dies implizieren
dass auch die fähigkeit durch erlebnis
hafte eigenschaften charakterisiert wäre
das wäre jedoch nicht nur zirkuläre
sondern auch begrifflich in korinth ja
weil eine fähigkeit eine disposition
aale eigenschaft ist die eben nicht
durch erlebnis hafte eigenschaften
gekennzeichnet sein kann
insgesamt zeigen also all diese
überlegungen dass die kontinuität des
erlebens als kriterium für personale
identität über die zeit hinweg scheitert
damit stellt sich allerdings die frage
welche allgemeinen schlüssel sich
hieraus ziehen lassen und zwar
hinsichtlich der rolle die qualitative
eigenschaften mentale zustände im
kontext personale identität überhaupt
spielen können ist man nun zu der
aussage genötigt dass die kontinuität
des erlebens in gar keiner sinnvollen
weise zur analyse zeit über grabner
personenidentität beitragen können
meines erachtens volk dies nicht
zwingend aus den vorgebrachten einwänden
um die relevanz der kontinuität des
erlebens zu verdeutlichen muss
allerdings das philosophische problem
anders formuliert werden anstelle von
kriterien muss die struktur eines
bestimmten psychischen zustands in den
fokus genommen werden
es ist ja eine tatsache dass personen
sich das hatte ich eingangs schon
erwähnt sich normalerweise ihrer
zeitlichen existenz bewusst sind das
heißt sie verfügen üblicherweise über
ein bewusstsein dass sie bereits zu
früheren zeitpunkten existiert haben
um dieses psychische phänomen genauer zu
klären zu expliziten ist die suche nach
notwendigen und hinreichenden
bedingungen personale identität nicht
zielführend die frage muss vielmehr
lauten was heißt es ein bewusstsein der
eigenen zeit übergreifenden identität zu
hören
diese frage verändert das philosophische
problem in entscheidender weise um ein
solches psychisches phänomen besser zu
verstehen müssen strukturelle
eigenschaften und bedingungen in den
blick genommen werden und das werde ich
nun tun zunächst bedarf es einer
wichtigen unterscheidung offenbar gibt
es zwei verschiedene typen von mentalen
zuständen die in bezug auf das
bewusstsein zeit übergreifender
numerischer identität einer person
relevant sind eine form die eine
reflexive und auch logisch folgende
struktur aufweist und eine die das nicht
tut
die erste tritt typischerweise auf wenn
jemand beispielsweise explizit über
seine vergangenheit nachdenkt was dann
in entsprechenden urteilen numerischer
identität ausgedrückt wird etwa ich bin
als kind in norddeutschland zur schule
gegangen ja was die aussage impliziert
ich bin diejenige oder dieselbe person
die vor etlicher zeit ein leben und dem
ort in norddeutschland zur schule
gegangen ist diese mentalen gehalte
setzen oftmals forderungen aus anderen
mentalen zuständen voraus zum beispiel
aus überzeugung und autobiografischen
episodischen erinnerungen zum teil aus
eigenen oder auch aus erinnerungen
anderer personen
die zweite variante ist zu verstehen als
ein implizites gewahrsam der eigenen
trans temporalen identität ein
bewusstsein das nicht auf einer
reflexion oder einer logischen operation
basiert
dies spiegelt sich in der schon bereits
erwähnten alltags wahrnehmung wieder den
personen sind sich normalerweise
unmittelbar und ohne kognitive
anstrengungen ihrer zeit übergreifenden
existenz bewusst
es handelt sich dabei um ein ball saales
gewissermaßen automatisch generiertes
gewahr sein auf das man demnach nicht
seine aufmerksamkeit erst richten muss
um es zu haben oder gedanken darauf
richten muss es ist vor allem genau
diese zweite form des identitäts
bewusstseins von personen bei der die
eigenschaft der kontinuität des erlebens
die ich vorhin im zusammenhang mit dance
argument diskutiert habe noch einmal ins
spiel kommt die kontinuität des erlebens
also in der art wie denken sie versteht
hängt meines erachtens funktional mit
dem unmittelbaren identitäts bewusstsein
von personen zusammen also in dem
zweiten beschriebenen sinn das erleben
des eigenen anhaltenden
bewusstseinsstrom
das erleben von kobe wussten und sich
überlappenden mentalen zuständen scheint
für das zeit übergreifende identitäts
bewusstsein notwendig zu sein denn diese
eigenschaften enthalten nicht nur
informationen über das zeitliche fließen
meiner erfahrung und erlebnisse sondern
was entscheidend ist über mich als ford
existieren ist subjekt der ereignisse ja
wenn ein auto auf der straße vor meinem
fenster vorbei fährt höre ich ein
langgezogenes geräusch das im hinblick
auf lautstärke und intensität variiert
relativ zur entfernung des autos das
zeitlich andauernde klangerlebnis ist
ein aspekt des gesamtzustandes ein
anderer aspekt ist die kontinuität
meines erlebens der ich mir ebenfalls
bewusst bin diese beschreibung sie
werden es schon ahnen ist allerdings mit
demselben problem konfrontiert wie der
kritisierte ansatz von denken nämlich
dem rückenproblemen so wie es genannt
hatte
die kernaussage des rückens pro brücken
problems ist dass die kontinuität des
erlebens immer wieder unterbrochen wird
mindestens in phasen des traum losen
schlafs das problem schlägt auch hierzu
und betrifft die begrenzte zeitliche
tiefe oder reichweite von
kontinuierlichem erleben bewusstseins
ströme so kann man sagen dauern maximal
18 stunden an
wäre die kontinuität des erlebens die
einzige informationsquelle für das zeit
übergreifende numerische identitäts
bewusstsein von personen dann wäre
dessen zeitliche spanne ziemlich schmal
das widerspricht jedoch dem faktischen
erleben der eigenen zeitlichen existenz
das identitäts bewusstsein von personen
bezieht sich normalerweise auf eine
deutlich größere zeitliche dauer als
diejenige die durch phänomenale
kontinuität überhaupt vermittelt werden
kann
personen sind sich dessen implizit
bewusst dass sie eine längere
vergangenheit haben obwohl die
kontinuität des erlebens offenbar
notwendig ist für das trans temporale
identitäts bewusstsein ist es jedoch
keineswegs hinreichend es kann mich
beispielsweise nicht darüber informieren
dass ich gestern erfahrungen gemacht
habe geschweige denn einige jahre vorher
oder gar in meiner kindheit
insofern bedarf es eines anderen
kandidaten der genau diesen aspekt des
trans temporalen identitäts bewusstseins
erklärt könnten erinnerungen diese
funktion erfüllen
man könnte argumentieren dass eine
person ein bewusstsein ihrer eigenen
fortexistenz hat weil sie über
erinnerungen an ereignisse verfügt die
ihre vergangenen ergebnisse
repräsentieren und damit zugleich die
tatsache dass sie diejenige ist die
diese erlebnisse hatte wenn dies
zutrifft dann wäre die erinnerung eine
weitere voraussetzung für das trans
temporale identitäts bewusstsein von
personen auf den ersten blick lässt sich
kaum bestreiten dass das der fall ist
allerdings stellt sich die frage worauf
diese überlegungen eigentlich basiert
denn was heißt es dass sich jemand an
ein bestimmtes ereignis erinnert und
damit meine ich eben eine frühere
persönliche erfahrungen und nicht ein
historisches faktum wenn jemand sich
konkret daran erinnert im ersten
schuljahr von einem schneeball am kopf
getroffen worden zu sein dann
vergegenwärtigt sich die person dieses
ereignis das sie selbst früher erlebt
hat genauer sie repräsentiert dieses
ereignis als eins ihrer früheren
erlebnisse was ihre frühere existenz
impliziert zu bedenken ist jedoch dass
sowohl konkrete erinnerungen als auch
das von ihnen abgeleitete verständnis
der eigenen trans temporalen identität
reflexiv strukturiert ist allerdings
sollte es hier ja gerade um das nicht
reflexive also dieses implizite
identitäts bewusstsein gehen
ein struktureller aspekt mentaler
zustände wird also gesucht der zum einen
nicht reflexiv ist und der zum anderen
das bewusstsein einer längeren
zeitlichen streckung erklärt aus
begreiflichen gründen kommen zwei
kandidaten in frage
erstens implizite erinnerungen die
funktional auf das identitäts
bewusstsein bezogen sind ohne dass eine
reflexion erforderlich wäre
und zweitens qualitative eigenschaften
von konkreten erinnerungen zum ersten
punkt wenn ich mich als individuum
begreife das als einheitliches subjekt
in der zeit besteht dann habe ich nur
ein unmittelbares erleben meiner
kontinuierlichen erfahrungen nicht also
da habe ich nicht nur ein unmittelbares
erleben bei einer kontinuierlichen
erfahrungen vielmehr stützt sich das
trans temporale einheitsgefühl auch auf
erinnerung die aber eben nicht konkret
bewusst sein müssen
ich verfüge beispielsweise über latente
oder auch diffuse erinnerungen an
situationen die ich in der vergangenheit
erlebt habe und ich verfüge zum beispiel
über implizite erinnerung an orte an
denen ich in der vergangenheit
habe auch spielt das implizite wissen
von fakten die ich nicht selbst erlebt
habe sondern die ich von anderen weiß
eine wichtige rolle zum beispiel über
den zeitpunkt und ort meiner geburt
diese erinnerungen müssen aber eben
nicht konkret abgerufen und bewusst
gemacht werden um eine funktion für das
identitäts bewusstsein von personen
auszuüben
ihre rolle besteht darin dass sie
oftmals lediglich im hintergrund präsent
sind und mein zeit übergreifendes selbst
erleben beeinflussen welche eigenschaft
von erinnerung ist aber genau für diese
information verantwortlich erinnerungen
an frühere erlebnisse sind durch einen
qualitativen aspekt gezeigt
gekennzeichnet dies wird aus der
perspektive der ersten person deutlich
der prozess des konkreten erinnert er
inanc ist von einem typischen erleben
begleitet welches ihn von anderen
mentalen prozessen wie denken
vorstellungen stellen oder wahrnehmen
unterscheidbar macht so gibt es einen
ausschlaggebenden qualitativen oder
phänomenalen unterschied zwischen dem
aktuellen tatsächlichen sehen eines
papageis im garten also der
repräsentation des papageis hier und
jetzt und dem erinnern anders sehen des
papageis vielleicht am tag zuvor also
der repräsentation der gestrigen
repräsentation des papageis diese
beobachtung wird von empirischen studien
unterstützt insbesondere von den
arbeiten endet allerdings zum episodisch
autobiografische gedächtnis das
episodische autobiografische gedächtnis
speichert kontext gebundene ereignisse
der eigenen vergangenheit teil ring
zufolge sind episodisch autobiografische
erinnerungen mit einer spezifischen
phänomenalen eigenschaft verbunden die
er als autor ethisches bewusstsein oder
otto nötig coaches mist bezeichnet
es handelt sich dabei um den typischen
qualitativen charakter episodisch
autobiografisch erinnerung ist ein zitat
wenn eine person remember special event
hieß aware of the event essay the part
of his past existenz nachteil bing kommt
der qualitativen eigenschaft also den
automatischen bewusstsein die funktion
zu das bewusstsein der eigenen trans
temporalen existenz zu vermitteln die
enge verbindung zwischen episodisch
autobiografischen erinnerungen und der
genannten qualitativen eigenschaft
konnten auch in klinischen studien
gezeigt werden die mit einem
amnesiepatienten durchgeführt wurde
die die fähigkeit des patienten sich an
fakten zu erinnern also sein sogenanntes
semantisches gedächtnis war normal
ausgeprägt ja er konnte sich an fakten
und daten auch seines eigenen lebens
erinnern
zum beispiel daran in welchem jahr seine
familie in das haus einzog in dem sie
heute noch wohnt allerdings waren diese
erinnerung von einer nicht persönlichen
erlebnis qualität begleitet vergleichbar
also mit der erlebnisqualität die
erinnerung an fakten und daten an
historische fakten begleitet meines
erachtens ist es genau diese von timing
beschriebene subjekt bezogene
erlebnisqualität episodisch
autobiografischer erinnerung die das
unmittelbare zeit übergreifende
identitäts bewusstsein weiter erklärt
gestützt wird dies auch durch die
alltagserfahrung es kommt nicht selten
vor dass erinnerungen auftreten ohne
dass man bewusst auf ihren gehalt achtet
oder ihn sich vergegenwärtigt
metaphorisch gesprochen
tauchen episodisch autobiografische
erinnerung manchmal beiläufig und
assoziativ auf beispielsweise wenn man
einen gegenstand sieht der einen etwas
an etwas erinnert dass man vor einigen
jahren gesehen oder erlebt hat ja man
muss aber dann nicht konkret denn die
aufmerksamkeit und einen konkreten
gedanken darauf
entwickeln sondern es bleibt dann so
eine so eine erinnerungs spur im jetzt
bewusst seien flüchtig bemerkt man dies
ohne eine klare repräsentation davon zu
haben
ich muss mich also nicht konkret dem
gehalt einer erinnerung zu wenden um
anschließend ableiten zu können dass es
sich bei dem erfahrungs subjekt zu
repräsentierten zeit um mich als das
identische erfahrungs objekt handelte
festzuhalten ist dass die
erlebnisqualität von erinnerungen durch
zwei wichtige merkmale charakterisiert
sind sie enthält und vermittelt dem
geschmack oder das gefühl des
vergangenen und sie ist subjekt bezogen
insgesamt gesehen sind es meines
erachtens vor allem diese beiden typen
qualitativen eigenschaften zum einen die
kontinuität des erlebens zum anderen die
erlebnisqualität von erinnerungen auf
denen das implizite bewusstsein basiert
als numerische identisches erfahrung
subjekt über die zeit hinweg zu
existieren und damit komme ich zum
schluss
ich habe in meinem vortrag zwei sehr
unterschiedliche probleme ansätze
diskutiert die in verschiedener weise
das begriffliche verhältnis von
qualitativen erleben und personale
identität über die zeit hinweg
thematisieren
ich habe am beispiel von barry denkens
argument gezeigt dass der versuch
qualitatives erleben als kriterium zu
begründen mit unüberwindbaren
schwierigkeiten verbunden ist
ich habe anschließend vorgeschlagen das
philosophische problem anders zu
fokussieren um die theoretische
bedeutung von qualitativen erleben für
personale identität sichtbar zu machen
dies führte zur analyse des zeit
übergreifenden numerischen identitäts
bewusstseins von personen von dem ich
gezeigt habe dass qualitatives erleben
eine zentrale bedingung ist und zwar
sowohl in form der sich zeitlich
andauern den bewusstseinsstrom als auch
in form von qualitativen eigenschaften
impliziter episodische erinnerung das
identitäts bewusstsein ist meines
erachtens in grundlegender weise auf das
selbstverständnis also auf ein reicheres
selbstverständnis von personen bezogen
wenn man sich zum beispiel charakter
eigenschaften zuschreibt ja und sich
dabei auch auf konkrete erfahrungen
erlebnisse entscheidung und handlung
früherer lebens episoden bezieht dann
geschieht dies auf der grundlage des
bewusstseins als identisches erfahrungs
subjekt in der zeit zu existieren
darüber hinaus hat dies folgen für das
moralische selbstverständnis denn nur
wenn man sich als numerisch identisches
erfahrung subjekt begreift dass über die
zeit hinweg existiert kann man sich für
frühere handlungen die man ausgeführt
hat verantwortlich fühlen
vielen dank